So one of the prevailing
motifs here on "Shots of Awe"
is as human beings--
as conscious agents--
how do we resolve the inherent
tension between wanting
to realize-- to fully
realize-- our potential,
to realize ourselves
as individuals
who stand with dignity and
resist the tug of conformity?
How do we avoid succumbing
to a zombified trance
state of blindly following
others in a herd-- as sheep,
as hamsters in a hamster wheel.
And [LAUGHS] it's funny.
Because I think that
the way we resolve that
is by taking that
plunge-- by answering
that call that Joseph
Campbell talks about.
There is no one map for
how to live our lives.
Reality is just a word.
And you're not
supposed to use it
without quotation
marks around it anyway,
as Joseph Campbell says.
We are all free to
create our own reality.
But it's only when
we are bold enough
to decondition our thinking--
to transcend what Robert Anton
Wilson calls the reality
tunnel-- this linguistic,
and conceptual, and symbolic
framework that constructs
your realities, and a matrix
pulled in front of your eyes,
blinding you from
ecstatic visions of what
might be behind those walls.
We are larvas who haven't turned
ourselves into butterflies yet.
And there's that great line
by Nietzsche that says,
"those who were seen
dancing were called insane
by those who could
not hear the music."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Never forget the words of
Jack Kerouac. "The only people
for me are the mad
ones-- mad to live,
mad to talk, mad to be
saved, desirous of everything
at the same time.
Those who would never yawn
or say a commonplace thing
but burn, burn, burn
like yellow Roman candles
exploding like spiders
across the sky."
[MUSIC PLAYING]